what's going on guys this is rob and as
we know CBS has effectively leaked the
trailer for Supergirl online and and
imagine they probably done this to kind
of gauge reaction to it to see you know
how people feel about it so far and and
that's what I want to do here I want to
talk in this show or end up this video
rather about Kara Argus Cara zor-el
herself about the character of Supergirl
but I also want to talk about a couple
of the easter eggs that we get and some
of the characters that have been recast
because there's some interesting recast
and some interesting creations that have
been made for the sake of this TV show
so starting out with cara zor-el herself
the way she's introduced to us she of
course is again the cousin of Superman
of Clark Kent or I guess of kal-el she
is apparently was sent after him for the
purpose of protecting him when he had
been sitting by jor-el in order to
escape the fate of planet Krypton in
addition to this she was locked into the
Phantom Zone for a little while she
managed to escape at which point she
landed on the planet Earth and she got
there where she was about 12 now we're
not exactly told how it was this had
happened was somehow or another she had
ended up with her foster family now this
is where things kind of take a little
bit of a turn rather than her being the
the only member of her family the only
daughter of her adoptive family instead
they basically cast a woman named Alex
Danvers to be her sister now Alex
Danvers appears to be the biological
daughter of these two parents with Cara
zor-el being the adoptive daughter now
as far as I've been able to tell the
Alexander Alex Danvers doesn't exist in
DC Comics she's not there and so you
know I could be wrong here again I'm
forgive my knowledge about my lack of
knowledge i guess about DC Comics but
yeah it seems as though she's simply
been created for the TV show which isn't
a bad thing because her characters
actually pretty decent you know she she
doesn't really do a whole lot I mean she
does you know later on but the way she's
initially given to us it's quite clear
that the star of the show is Cara zor-el
is a Supergirl now having said that we
get a couple Easter eggs here the mother
of Korra's RL the adoptive mother is
actually the same woman that played
super girl in the original film and the
adoptive father is Dean Cain he's the
guy that played Superman and the
adventures of Lois and Clark oh so I'm
really really excited about that yeah I
think it's kind of cool you know
hopefully Dean Cain gets I get Dean Cain
and the woman get more get more
involvement as the show goes on they
weren't really given that we don't get
their names and so it may just be that
we're just never going to see them again
I don't really know here I hope we do
you know because again the
played a very prominent role in the life
of Superman oh so I'm hoping that we're
also going to see the Danvers play a
very prominent role in the life of cars
or L and that I think is where things
start to take a change I want to talk
about this for a second but I want to
talk about the character of Supergirl
here in terms of how she exists
initially and I think this was a concern
of a lot of people when the pilot came
out that we were basically going to see
the introduction of a knock off Superman
people were going to say well I mean
she's not really Superman but they need
to show about somebody who's like
Superman so we'll just get super girl
and whatever nobody will ask questions
that's not the case those of you ladies
out there who are looking for a super
girl who was strong and who was
confident who had a little bit of doubt
about her skills in the beginning but
over over time gains a confidence to use
her skills effectively those of you are
those of you ladies out there who were
looking for a female superhero that's a
reflection of what it means to be a
woman in society today a woman in the
workplace different things like that the
kind of struggles that go along with it
you're gonna love this show this show is
so going to be for you I mean this is it
really gives you an honest depiction at
least as far as I can tell from a man's
perspective what it means to be a woman
in society today having said that we
actually get these dichotomies of
feminism this is what I really really
like here calista flockhart is cast as
the boss or i guess the head of cat
corporation the boss of a car is RL in
this TV series and calista flockhart
represents the sort of militant feminism
whereas cars are l represents the sort
of equal feminism and there's there's a
big deal there's a big difference
between the two and and of course I
think a lot of people gonna latch on to
the car is orell version of feminism or
they simply say it's not about you know
being overpowering it's not about being
dominant it's about being equal that's
what I really really like here what we
also get is a recasting of Jimmy Olsen
now the recasting of Jimmy Olsen has
done very tastefully here again what we
basically seen is CBS taking into
account that cars are l needs to be able
to stand on her two feet she needs to be
the star of the show and so Jimmy Olsen
is cast in a way to where he's really
more of a guide where he basically says
here's the things your cousin's figured
our that your cousin figured out while
he became a superhero in Metropolis
because remember Jimmy Olsen was there
every step of the way from the time that
that kal-el first arrived in Metropolis
to the time that he became a superhero
became superman in Metropolis now of
course Jimmy Olsen wasn't aware for a
good majority of the time that Clark
Kent and Superman were the same person
but nonetheless he was there to watch
the character grow as time progressed so
he basically passed this knowledge on to
Supergirl and basically say here's the
steps your cousin took you know he wants
you to grow on your own that's really
cool the cool thing here I mean we see a
couple instances of Superman we actually
see Superman up here a couple times we
don't really see his face there's no
characters we don't know no actor that's
been assigned to his role in the sense
that will see him as a mainstay it's
really just sort of giving credence to
the fact that she's equal to Superman
which is which is a really cool concept
here having said that you know the show
itself gives us a couple changes for
example of our touch i think his name
was and the comics he's a superhero he's
a good guy he fights on behalf of
Superman fights with Superman in a
couple instances he's actually more
powerful than Superman it really kind of
depends on who's riding him and and the
circumstances and so on in this show
he's a villain and so the way the
villains have been given to us are
really kind of shaky here basically what
they say is there is a prison in the
Phantom Zone and when the Phantom when
they manage to get out of the Phantom
Zone they basically show up on the
planet Earth and they've kind of spread
across the earth which gives us the
basis behind the first season of the
show she's going to be traveling around
rounding up villains not really sure how
I feel about that um it's kind of ok
well Sal send me a message on skype so
it's kind of thrown in there it feels
like the basis for the villains it just
kind of slammed in there what they
weren't really sure where to go with
villains so they just kind of said let's
just have her be a big fish net and just
round up all these different villains
not a bad thing it depends on how they
play them out it depends on the villains
that we're going to see but the fact
remains here that in terms of being a
pilot with it being being a show that I
guess being a part of it establishes the
basis of the show this show has a lot of
great potential it really has a it
really has a green arrow / flash feel to
it in the sense that it feels much like
those pilots but it also feels like
it'll go the same direction and this is
what I really like because a flash and
green arrow have been stellar shows
they've been amazing I mean Stephen
Amell has been unbelievable you know in
the role of green arrow and flash is no
different so you know I'm really
hoping that we continue this trend I'm
really hoping we continue to see it go
the same way now having said that for
you guys out there for the fellas the
gentleman if you are looking for
beautiful women in a TV show you get it
you get that you get beautiful women in
a TV show I don't mean to say that to
minimalize you know to marginalize
marginalize men and into believing that
all they want or just women but they are
definitely they are definitely very
attractive the super girl and her outfit
is definitely very attractive and so
that will definitely appear to a lot of
the younger crowd to a lot of the
younger boys but nonetheless you know
for for those who are going into it you
know looking for a strong confident
woman who is learning as she goes along
stepping into the role of Supergirl
that's what you get for those of you who
are looking for a really solid plot you
get that to a degree but again this is
just a pilot there's a lot of time to
make improvement the show can be very
very long and and there's plenty of room
to grow here so I would not like any
stretch of the imagination discount the
show basically what we see in the pilot
so far then of course for those of you
guys who are looking for strong male
figures those of you guys who we're
looking for familiar faces Jimmy Olsen
and so on you get that and so this is a
really well crafted and very
well-rounded TV show so far I think so
what that being said we're going to
bring this video to an end hope you guys
enjoyed it if you did let me know and
I'm looking forward to it so uh yeah I
will catch you guys later peace but we
had one more important sound we wanted
you to hear